>> Juan: DEMOCRATS ARE HAVING
SERIOUS REGRETS FOR FORCING
AL FRANKEN OUT OF OFFICE.
HE RESIGNED IN 2017 OVER
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT ALLEGATIONS
AFTER WIDESPREAD PRESSURE FROM
WITHIN HIS OWN PARTY.
BUT NOW, A NEW YORKER ARTICLE
WRIST FIELD SEVERAL DEMOCRATIC
OFFICERS WISHES HE NEVER STEPPED
INSIDE.
AND HE SAID I WILL NEVER DO
SOMETHING, THAT ISN'T ALWAYS THE
CASE.
SO WHILE SOME DEMOCRATS SAY THEY
MADE A MISTAKE, ONE OF FRANKEN'S
BIGGEST CRITICS SENATOR KIRSTEN
GILLIBRAND IS DOUBLING DOWN.
>> WASN'T DENIED ANYTHING.
IT WAS HIS AND HIS ALONE,
WHETHER TO WAIT FOR HIS NEXT
ELECTION.
THE DECISION I MADE WAS WHETHER
OR NOT TO SOMEHOW BLAMING ME FOR
A MAN'S ACTIONS AND A MAN
DECISION IS PRETTY ABSURD.
>> FRANK, DO YOU THINK HE SHOULD
HAVE RESIGNED?
HE DIDN'T HAVE ANYTHING IN THE
COURT OF LAW, NO DUE PROCESS.
I'M THINKING SOMETIMES THESE
CASES CAN BE PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE
TIME CHANGES.
>> HE WAS PRETTY LOW ON THE
TOTEM POLE.
IF THIS WAS IN THE CONTEXT OF
THE DEMOCRATS WANTING TO LOOK
PURE WHILE THEY ARE TRYING TO
ATTACK DROID MORE.
IT WAS FRESH OFF THE HEELS OF
THE WEINSTEIN SITUATION SO THEY
WERE GOING TO GET KILLED WITH
WHAT ABOUT IS HIM AS THEY HAVE
STUCK BEHIND THIS TABLE.
>> BUT I THINK THE REAL DEAL IS
THE JANE MAYER WHO DID THIS
PIECE IS NOT A REAL JOURNALIST.
THIS IS A PUFF PIECE TO REHAB
HIS IMAGES AND HIS CAREER AND
SHE DIDN'T TREAT ANYONE IN THE
SAME WAY AS SHE WOULD HAVE
TREATED AL FRANKEN.
WHY DOESN'T SHE LOOK AT SOME OF
THE SEXUAL HARASSMENT LAWSUIT
SETTLEMENTS IN CONGRESS THAT THE
TAXPAYERS HAVE TO PLAY FOR?
NO.
SHE WAS A HEADACHE FOR THE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION, EXPLAINED THE
AGENTS AND NOW SHE'S BACK
HELPING PEOPLE WHO HATE TRUMP.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WITH
DEMOCRATS.
THEY ONLY AND ANY TIME YOU USE
IT IT'S CONVICTION.
SHE POKES HOLES AND YOU ACCUSER
SAID THE PHOTO WITH THIS WAS
TAKEN DECEMBER 24.
SHE SAYS OH, NO, IT WAS TAKEN
DECEMBER 21.
THAT'S A BIG HOLE, I THINK WE
ARE, BUT ULTIMATELY THE PLATE
STUMBLING ON THE GROUND BUT I
STILL THINK -- BRING BACK THE
SLAB RULE.
ONCE A MAN GETS FRESH, SLAP THEM
RIGHT IN THE FACE.
>> I'M THINKING TO MYSELF ABOUT
FINGER SNAPS, JESSE HAD RIGHTLY
MENTIONED THAT SHE HAD WRITTEN A
PIECE ABOUT THE CAVANAUGH.
SO I'M THINKING WHAT ARE THE
STANDARD OFFICIALS WITH REGARDS
TO INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR?
BECAUSE TO ME IT LOOKS LIKE WHEN
THE CHARGES ARE AGAINST THE
DEMOCRAT YOU DON'T GET AWAY BUT
WHEN IT'S AGAINST THE OTHER ONE,
YOU DO.
>> THEY CAME OUT WITH A 400 PAGE
REPORT AND HE WAS CONFIRMED
SHOWING THAT NOT A SINGLE
ACCUSATION AGAINST HIM PANNED
OUT AND DIDN'T HAVE ANY KIND OF
EVIDENCE.
SO HE ASKED WITH A SUBSTANDARD
IS, THE STANDARD AS EVIDENCE,
NOT JUMPING TO CONCLUSIONS AND
NOT NECESSARILY BELIEVING WOMEN
BUT TAKING THEM SERIOUSLY MAKING
SURE YOU WEIGH BOTH SIDES OF THE
STORY IT SAYS SHE -- THERE IS NO
SUCH EVIDENCE PRESENTED.
>> THERE WAS PHOTO THAT WAS
PRESENTED AND INFORMATION.
>> THERE IS NO INFORMATION OR
EVIDENCE PRESENTED AT ALL
OUTSIDE OF ACCUSATIONS FROM 30
YEARS AGO.
THEY ALSO CONNECTED TO THE
ACCUSERS WHO DEMOCRAT WAS TRYING
TO TAKE DOWN SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE BRETT KAVANAUGH.
SO THE STANDARD IS, EVERYBODY
TAKE A BREATH.
YOU CANNOT CONTINUE TO PUSH
FORWARD FALSE ALLEGATIONS OR
JUMP TO CONCLUSION BECAUSE IT
HURTS PEOPLE WHO HAVE REAL CASES
AGAINST MEN WHO ARE ABUSERS OR
PREDATORS.
>> Juan: DO YOU THINK YOU
SHOULD HAVE RESIGNED?
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE
SHOULD HAVE DONE BUT SHE WAS
LEADING THE CHARGE SO SHE
CERTAINLY HAD SOMETHING TO DO
WITH THE PRESSURE ON HIM.
>> Juan: SO, THE WOMEN AREN'T
HEARD AND IS THAT ALL YOU WANT?
IS THAT NOT FAIR?
>> Dagan: I THINK THEY'VE BEEN
HEARD IN MANY OF FORUMS.
WHAT'S THE POINT OF THIS ARTICLE
IN THE NEW YORKER?
FOR HIM, HE'S THE VICTIM.
WHEN YOU TALKED ABOUT THAT PHOTO
OF LEANNE TWEED AND, SHE WAS
ASLEEP.
HE GOT AWAY WITH THAT IN PART
AND THEY ARE MAKING EXCUSES FOR
IT NOW BECAUSE, OH, HE'S A
COMEDIAN.
WHAT'S THE POINT OF THE ARTICLE
IN THE NEW YORKER, TO SEND A
MESSAGE TO DEMOCRATS AND LIBERAL
MEN OF LIKE, NEXT TIME WE WILL
GO EASY ON YOU.
BUT TO THE REPUBLICANS, THEY
WILL BAKE, FRY AND MICROWAVE YOU
UNTIL THERE IS NOTHING LEFT.
>> Juan: WHILE, I THINK HE IS
STILL PRESIDENT.
SO GREG, I WAS THINKING ABOUT
THIS AND I THOUGHT TO MYSELF,
WHAT SANCTIONS ARE IN PLACE?
YOU GET SOMEONE LIKE THAT GUY
LIKE STEVE KING, REPUBLICANS CAN
SCRIPT TO HIM BUT THEY DON'T
MAKE HIM RESIGN.
THE DEMOCRATS MADE HIM GET OUT.
>> THEY DIDN'T MAKE HIM DO
ANYTHING.
>> Jesse: 'S PARTY ATE HIM
ALIVE.
HOWEVER, HE IS NOT INNOCENT.
I KNOW PERSONALLY TO PEOPLE THAT
HE DID THIS TO.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT, NOT JUST
LIANA.
WE KNOW KATHY LEE GOT -- IF
FRANK GIFFORD WERE ALIVE TODAY
HE WOULD BEAT THE OUT OF
AL FRANKEN.
SO I THINK EVERYBODY KNEW THIS
ABOUT AL FRANKEN.
HE USED TO GRAB PEOPLE AND
BECAUSE THEM, HE BRAGGED ABOUT
IT ON HOWARD STERN OR HE TALKED
ABOUT IN THE GREEN ROOM AND
THERE IS VISUAL EVIDENCE THAT
JANE MAY OR IGNORED.
SHE USED GOSSIP TO DESTROY
CAVANAUGH BUT THERE WERE
ACTUALLY STORIES ABOUT
AL FRANKEN.
I WISH HE HAD DUE PROCESS UNDER
WHICH HE STUCK AROUND.
I WISH HE HAD ACTUALLY BEEN
QUESTIONED.
BUT LIKE A LOT OF PEOPLE, HE HAD
THE PROGRESSIVE PIG PASS.
THEY SURVIVE AND THRIVE AS LONG
AS THEY SUPPORT DEMOCRATS AND
THEY LOOK THE OTHER WAY.